[Music]
okay everybody so this is my review of
the wheel of time episode 7 the dark
along the ways it's crazy we are already
at the penultimate episode of the season
i can't believe it uh there's only eight
episodes in the season but i feel like
it just started so it's fascinating that
we're already at the end here but you
always see with penultimate episodes in
a season that sometimes it's more of a
setup for a big finale or it's the big
episode and then the finale is kind of a
calm down but this clearly is one that
is actually a setup for the finale and
it's interesting because with the
cliffhanger last week it felt like maybe
this was going to be kind of like a
banger but it's really not but
that's for better or for worse and that
always can pay off again if the finale
lands and gives us what we really want
is that big episode so what i did like
about this episode is it has a great
cold open like episode four did with
logan where this time we're seeing this
pregnant warrior that's in like
something that looks like hoth from star
wars and it will be revealed at the end
of the episode that this is rand's
mother with the red hair
and it will also reveal that rand is the
dragon reborn and that this is on i
guess this area if i heard a correctly
dragon mill so i guess that connects it
to why he is the dragon reborn if maybe
we can get some clarification from book
readers on that and why that's the case
because it wasn't super clear in this
episode but really stood out to me this
cold open was of course the action was
really good the fighting choreography
was great here but i also love the
confident camera work with a lot of just
shots that are constantly changing
perspective in the scene and i really
really dug the sound mixing and sound
design in this scene in particular
sound never gets enough praise and all
kind of works and this really stood out
to me here so props to the whole team on
this opening action sequence so what is
an interesting storyline when we go back
now to present day you know moraine's
reaction to matt not coming along
everyone's reaction but moraine's was
really important to me because when lan
asks her you know what if it's matt the
dragon and we don't have them she's
happy he's not you know going with them
in a sense because she sees inherent
darkness in matt in general so
she's like if he was the dragon and he
sees the dark one he would probably just
go and you know be with the dark one and
be on his side which would be really bad
so i thought that was interesting and i
think it's interesting later on the
episode that she sends a message
to the white tower that the red
asha should look for matt this is crazy
because this is like i guess sending him
to a death sentence because we know how
they feel
about men and clearly powerful men like
matt so
this is really interesting too that she
made this choice that she's
really sending matt to something bad for
him and
you know obviously the other people in
the group don't know she did this so
this will also definitely come back
later on now where things i thought were
a little murky in this episode was this
storyline between this love triangle
that didn't really feel
necessary at the moment or just felt
rushed how they just kind of really made
it a love triangle thing this episode
where we see that there's this little
moment of perrin being jealous of eguin
and rand cuddling while they're in this
ways area and
i thought it was just strange how later
on the episode they all fight about this
and naive says the line that you know
it's like you two keep fighting over
like she's some reward to be one eguin
i don't know where this was developed
and then they start talking about like
rand saying oh i always knew you
proposed to your wife the day i got
iguain but even if it was something in
the past you didn't really see it was
strange that there wasn't points of like
flirting or that being set up with
parent and gwen in this time when they
were with the hippies so i thought it
just felt as an audience member very out
of left field and weird uh and it didn't
feel earned at all so that was something
that was
bizarre to me and it was just a bizarre
love triangle that wasn't clicking and
that just because i don't know where
ever we were developed anything between
parent and equine so i thought that was
really strange and where would naive
have learned this information that we
didn't and even if it was way in the
past you know maybe something to have
shown us that maybe i'm forgetting
something but i really don't think there
was anything here to kind of lend itself
to that so what was really cool was when
moraine talks about the black wind when
they're in this area and she's like
don't listen to it so let's go through
all these black wind voices we hear
through each character because moraine
it says you will murder these children
and call it heroism which is really
interesting it wayne's like you're an
imposter and we'll never love you as
much as you love him not really that
interesting but rand it says she left
you once and she will leave you again
but they cut out what's part of the
reveal later where it talks about him
being the dragon reborn he knows he's
always been that that's his destiny so
we'll get into that line i'm butchering
it there but i'll revisit it towards the
end of the episode but they did leave
that out here and parents says you
wanted laina dead that's why you killed
her
and lands as you can't protect her you
watch her die but what's interesting is
naive is you will do nothing to save
them you can't protect them but she
already proves this voice wrong in this
moment if it's relating to this moment
because she does protect them and save
them and gets them out of this situation
and let me just say we've already seen
seven episodes the mvp of the show is
clearly
naive that's the actress zoe robbins
here but it's also the character and
she's just to me the most likable the
most smart and she's got this awesome
power about her she's super powerful so
she's kind of to me the voice of reason
here so i really think she stole the
show for sure and she does it again in
this episode so we see they get out of
the way gate they're in the borderlands
here and this is land's home which is
pretty cool and moraine's like i'm
giving a warning to this city like yo
like the dark ones coming with his army
you know block up the gates whatever you
have to do and makes it more serious to
them this lord of this land is very
cocky you know he thinks he's got all
under control but
there's more coming here what's
interesting is a lot of commenters shout
out to the commenters that are book
readers that have been telling me that
there's been someone following them we
see
this person is pat and feign who's the
peddler we met in episode one and he
comes through the way gate here and
perrin sees him in the town but naive
says no he's he's dead he died in this
trollic attack so
that's where they think he is that he's
not alive but he is following them so
that's gonna be interesting too so that
is confirmed
so what is interesting too is when they
get to this bar and moraine's going to
the psychic bartender and we get to see
her visions and perrin has yellow eyes
and run blood is running down his chin
but she's also like the redheads holding
a baby meaning rand but when moraine
asks about the girls the bartender says
white flame and a ring of gold but we
don't see
what she's seeing in that moment with
iguane and naive so it cuts to them when
she's talking about them as a group and
says that they do have a connection
which is rare and they're linked by
shadows and sparks and all this stuff so
and how more important the person is
with the clearer vision and she tells
moraine here too
that
the ambulance seat will be her downfall
which is basically who she's in love
with so that really shakes up moraine
here and i also think it's interesting
like i said that we didn't see
what she was exactly seeing with naive
and iguain something she's not telling
moraine clearly but look we see maureen
tells the group now the full story
basically that whoever is in the dragon
is going to die in this eye of the world
and says she wishes the bartender could
have told her who the dragon reborn is
but again by the end of episode she will
get that information from rand himself
but i love naive always brings moraine
down a notch you know a little bit of
like brings her ego down like look you
made your choice but we'll make our own
you can't drag the four of us against
our will but you see wayne's a very
honorable person here and is like
i want to go the eye of the world
because even if she is right she still
wants to save her family and the people
she loves and the world in general so
she is very honorable in that sense and
i love the writing here with how naive
and
rand are looking at moraine is like yeah
she can't lie but doesn't mean she can't
mislead and naive even says a great line
this is why she's a real mvp even if she
thinks she is telling the truth she
could be wrong so that's really big here
and again it would be boring if this
story unfolded oh yeah everything
maureen has said is completely accurate
like she's just nailed it and that's
what we're gonna see no clearly not so
obviously these kind of lines you see in
shows is probably what's going on so her
stuff gets a little interesting which is
the stuff with lan and naive and also
with moraine with land because moraine
is clearly shaken up about the
information she got about swan being her
downfall of course it's going to screw
you up right this is some when you trust
someone you love and getting that
information is never good but
lance sees something's off with her he
knows this but i like the moment
lan says to her he had nothing to live
for before her and this is earned and
sets up his talk with naive later
explaining you know his background and
what happened in his trauma but you see
moraine says to land i like her you know
the wisdom it's like okay so is this a
hall pass for land we're getting here
giving you a hall pass a what a what a
what a hall pass
and it's great so naive now is just
creeping on him watching what he's doing
at night she wants it way to take what
you want to you know it's very 2021 i
like it the female taken the first move
but i don't know if it was for a comic
moment but can lan teleport because he
noticed she's watching him and just
appears right in front of him i don't
know if that was just to make us kind of
laugh like
but it was it was bizarre too but you
know lan gets cold feet at the end of
the night doesn't kiss her when he
should but again 2021 baby even though
it's not 20 21 in this story it feels 20
20 because she comes back to the bedroom
door takes charge i nev i love it oh
behave
yeah
yeah baby
but you see there's some serious scars
on or they're even lashes it looks like
on land's body and before he even gets
to open up you know to naive it's like
he wakes up he's like yo you're leaving
so it's like she's not even staying for
an omelet but we learned lamb was
supposed to be a king but that land was
overrun by the blight and this is where
he tragically lost his family they were
slaughtered and that man we met was the
man who took him in but see naive has
this good line never understood why you
bond yourself to moraine a king without
a kingdom a boy without a family and now
you finally belong to her but he says
she doesn't own me only in the way those
kids own you which is interesting so
they're just going to get closer and
closer to these two and i think that's
been earned and developed throughout but
we'll see how much
he he gets close to her still because
maureen is that variable on how much
she's comfortable with him getting close
to naive and naive already has been set
up to always challenge moraine and that
just goes to with how powerful they both
are so i kind of like again how they're
setting that
inevitable butting of heads really
seriously between moraine and naive
later on i feel so we also see something
that'll probably excite a lot of fans
where eguin and rand actually make up
here and they talk about a gwain
should go follow her dreams of being a
nice to die rand says but they talk
about the idea that rand would be her
warder which is exciting maybe that's
something that will come true who knows
so this is where the episode really
ramps up here when rand we see this big
reveal of all the channeling rand has
already done and these moments we saw
that we weren't so clear what he was
doing and you have always known all
along you can't escape your fate you are
the dragon reborn is the line the wind
said to him but that that moment i'm
like can we trust this source of this
evil wind telling him that is it honest
but this is where ran goes to the
bartender's like i want you to tell me
that i'm not the dragon anymore but she
confirms that he is and she's like i saw
a baby born on the slopes of dragon mill
that baby was something impossible and
he asked her about the eye of the world
he's like do i make it back
she doesn't answer looks concerned and
he's like i didn't think so so that
makes you really interested for the
finale what's gonna happen with rand and
i like how they ramp up this awesome
cliffhanger to make you excited for the
finale because
you see wayne and parent are like to
naive you know we're going to go we're
ready to go with out of the world
they're ready to get everyone together
interestingly enough though naive still
seem hesitant which i think she's smart
on that thinking
and
it doesn't matter because random moraine
are already on their way he tells
moraine he's a dragon reborn and moraine
doesn't even tell lan and mask their
bond so land knows something's up that
makes this really exciting you got all
these people having people they love
that they might lose here and they know
there's a high chance of them dying so
stakes are really high and the stakes
are higher than ever because moraine and
rand have to go through the blight to
get to the eye of the world so like i
said it's a setup penultimate episode
for a big finale hopefully the big
finale lands because
again i'm sorry i'm repetitive with this
but the score to me again feels like an
8.8 what brings it down which would have
been a more better episode to me again
is that
bizarre love triangle not really feeling
like it's landing or earned
for the audience um but
a lot of good stuff here and
what's difficult about this is me giving
8.8 and looking at the c as a whole
there is a feeling in me that feels
empty though right and i don't feel like
my season score would even be an 8.8
it'd be lower than that so a lot of what
i feel about even these episodes depends
on how good the finale is like i feel
like there's a lot of pressure here
because if the finale stinks
i would actually bring this score down
on this episode so it's almost one
that's so hard to rate on its own
because i think it's so reliant on the
episode that comes after and so we'll
see and i think the whole season is that
like this season feels like
it is all mounting to a great epic close
but will we get that are they gonna you
know kind of tease us for season two
mostly i hope we get a good close to at
least
this rand and moraine moment in the
blight and in the eye of the world and
we might not but the episodes pretty
sure titled the eye of the world so
it looks like we're going to right and
that will set up something as a main
story for season 2 that's a little
different
i hope at least because if it feels like
it was just all teased to get to another
tease in this main story we're in and
not enough reward i'm gonna be
frustrated so that's the only feeling of
worry i have here because as a whole
season again i do feel like something is
still just missing that's not taking it
to its next level that it should be
getting to so i hope the finale takes it
to level we'll see but i still really
enjoyed this again i love the opening it
was my favorite part of the episode
there's a lot of interesting stuff
happening and as a non-book reader again
that's how i feel i don't i haven't read
any of the books or any spoilers of the
book so i don't know what's coming so
it's adding a lot to that suspense and
mystery but it could be different
experience for a book reader for sure so
i don't know how you feel but i'd love
to hear that as well but again with all
my reviews no
spoilers from the books please only
stuff we've already seen in the show and
if you want to clarify stuff that they
maybe have talked about that's not
really spoiler that's okay too but i i'm
really grateful for all you guys coming
here and commenting every week it's been
so much fun just reading all your stuff
you guys are great and you're very civil
so i appreciate that keep that up so
please follow me at steven's show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and please make sure to subscribe
so you don't miss one of my reviews of
the wheels time i'm also doing the
witcher season 2 right now so you can
check that out
and
also dexter and i do movie reviews and
celebrity interviews as well and if you
really ever do here i really appreciate
if you can donate to the channel by
becoming a member and you'll get
exclusive perks that will help me do
this full time one day so i can do more
reviews for you guys and i'll see you
next week for the big finale